the year of virtual reality is upon us
pre-orders for the oculus rift and the
HTC vive are already in full swing and
now Microsoft has entered the race you
can now apply to preorder a hollow lens
dev kit the asking price three thousand
dollars so what do you get for that arm
and leg you're spending well the
hololens dev kit includes the headset
and case but it is important to note
that the headset works without any
additional hardware also packed in is
young conquer a demo game starring
everyone's favorite Falmouth's squirrel
of course this younger version looks
very different but the hook is that the
game environment changes based on where
you're actually using the headset
everyone's experience will be different
also packed in as a shooter called robo
raid and a crime drama called fragments
keep in mind that this is not the final
version of the headset microsoft has
stated it won't rush the hollow lens to
market in an effort to avoid another
connect situation as such no consumer
price or release date has been announced
but if you want to drop three grand on
microsoft's AR / vr headset now you can
and if you're looking to keep up with
all the hollow lens news you're already
in the right place